when I was a kid five words filled me  with dread it's like riding a bike  because everyone can ride a bike right  unless you're from a family whose  favorite sports is eating second is  talking when a ball comes my way my  first instinct is to duck if you put me  on wing defence the only wings I'll  defend a barbecue chicken I never felt  the wind in my hair is will's kissed  tarmac the unchained melody of momentum  as tendons dismantle the air risking  twisted limbs to fling myself from ramps  fly down he'll fill every space with my  body and my body with space until my  spine is a white line dividing lanes and  I smash into each new second I am  breathing at 25 I got my first bike I  was the biggest kid in the park but I  tried no plan just five words do it or  you can disowning dignity to spin on  shaky feet until the world started  turning do it till you can  you